welcome to the pink marketing show the
number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
I'm Heather Torres and I'm Sean Connell
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening welcome
this show is dedicated to helping you
learn how to get your content notice and
the latest money-making strategies
working right now online so whether you
want to grow your YouTube channel or
maximize online video across social
media this is for you well on today's
episode we are bringing you another
keynote from our annual video conference
grow with video live it's a conference
we host here in Las Vegas every single
year and this year is going to be epic
but we want to share with you a
front-row seat
VIP all-access recording to the session
that I did at growers video live and I'm
excited to share with you how you can
overcome the seven enemies that are
keeping you from crushing it with video
right now you know we really fight a lot
of things when it comes to having
confidence on camera being able to press
that record button and create content
over the year and so I want to dive into
these seven enemies right now this
session for me is something that I
really wanted to bring to you because I
like most creators fight these enemies
daily and so for this session today we
are going to press record we're gonna go
through and the overcoming the 7 enemies
keeping you from crushing it with video
and here's the thing pressing record
change my life like Sean said four years
ago I had never uploaded a video I mean
that's crazy to think I'm standing on
this stage but four years ago I was
afraid to put my smartphone in front of
my face and just say hi to the world and
so as we go through these today we're
gonna crush and tackle external enemies
as well as internal enemies because I
know as a creator just like you I've
struggled with both of these the
external and the internal so let's go
ahead and just jump right in I like to
just jump into sessions
we're gonna first tackle the external
enemies now you saw this on Sean's
slides as well eighty-three percent of
marketers would increase their reliance
on video as a strategy if there were no
obstacles like time resources and budget
now as you saw I have a pretty full life
right I mean I think we all do raise
your head if you feel like you have a
pretty full life yes okay so I am not
alone in this situation now a few years
ago as I was starting my entrepreneurial
journey I was a mess I mean I'll just
admit it I was a complete mess I was
trying to juggle my family and starting
a business and having failures and all
of the things and a book was placed in
my hand called essentialism has anyone
read the book essentialism before all
right well it is an amazing book that I
highly recommend that you read and one
of the things that they tackle in that
book that was completely revolutionary
in my life was the idea of the lack of
time and the author of this book says if
you don't prioritize your life someone
else will you hear that if you do not
step up and prioritize your time your 24
hours guess what
someone else's agenda is going to ride
into there and like Lauren said you know
I'm a wife I'm a mom of three I'm
running this business but there are some
key staples of learning through
productivity that I want to share with
you today so here are my five four or
five I forget how many I put on here but
let's go through here's my productivity
tips that I use every single day in my
life and I want to pass these on to you
because these have been what has gotten
me here today so number one is I am a
preacher of calendar time blocking do I
have any time blockers in the audience
today let me tell you it is life
changing is it not it's amazing so
here's how I do this now if you are new
to calendars I'm gonna show you an
example of what my typical week would
look like but for what this looks like
right now is I want you to focus on what
is called an eye
P hey can you say that with me I key a
ok what is that an income producing
activities income producing activities
now we can fill our days with a lot of
things right like raise your hand if
you're like I could fill my day Heather
without a calendar easy no one okay well
you're all awesome
okay so income producing activities
these are the things that are actually
gonna move your business forward these
are the things that are actually gonna
move your relationships forward these
are the income producing activities that
are gonna get you to the next step in
your life and so what does this look
like for me well here's what a typical
week and Heather Torres's life would
look like so what this this is nicer
Simone oh my gosh I'm a busy woman
you know here's what this looks like now
I am a color code or any other color
coders yes I just love all the colors
they have a Google Calendar it's amazing
so this is a digital calendar that I use
and I love digital because let's be
honest life changes pretty fast right so
I worked on the regular type of calendar
for a long time trying to color coat
with my pens and you know playing my
journaling music and all that stuff and
it just stopped working because life
changes have three kids running a
business all the things so I need to be
able to change these things at a
moment's notice so if you're looking on
the screen here I want you to see that
what I do first in the day is actually
work on my side hustle anyone in here
with a side hustle yes the first thing I
do is work on my side hustle now for me
my side hustle right now actually is my
youtube channel the home school house so
on top of the other things we're doing
that is a passion project of mine and I
want to set aside time where I can move
that forward then I have my family time
but then when I clock into work the
first thing that I do is not check email
the first thing I do is not go to a
meeting the first thing that I use this
creative brain for is the IPAs that's
the first thing that I do and so I use
that time as say
time to write that email that I know I
need to get out to my customers or I use
that time to make the video content that
needs to be made that is sacred time
that's gonna move our business forward
so then after that you'll see that we
have admin that's where you fill in
emails that is other people's agenda and
so that comes later and then past that I
have additional work time family time
and shows you there but that is what
calendar blocking in a nutshell looks
like who can commit to calendar blocking
this next week any anyone you want to
commit to that awesome love that okay
well you know what happens when you are
working on your IPAs you start creating
some income because you're working on
income producing activities and so what
can happen there is now you have the
funds to be able to outsource tasks that
you do not need to be doing that is a
huge blocker when I'm with clients is
they are wanting to do it all anyone
feel like that they feel like I have to
do it all I can never release that thing
I can never just give that away I don't
want to hire a person for that well
guess what that is actually what's gonna
move your business forward so when you
start doing those IPAs you can start
outsourcing and you can start using
smart tools that are online so what we
use here I think media as well as or
here's some of the tools we used to
think media but we also if you've not
noticed we have hired a lot of people on
think media and you know what that is
scary like let's be honest
hiring a human who needs to pay their
bills is on you that is a hard thing but
you know what that is actually going to
produce more income in your business
kind of a weird blocker but these are
some of the tools that we use here I
think media and you'll notice I don't
have like an entire slide full of things
right there are four main things that
we're using here at think media why cuz
I don't want to be learning more
software anyone else not really into all
this ah be really I want to learn this
that I need to do this so I'm this plugs
into that thing and then this thing into
that thing you're like what am I doing
with my time I am NOT a software
developer okay I
not a software developer but these are
the things we use as a team we use
Google Calendar everyone on our team
everyone including my husband and
soon-to-be my children will be on Google
Calendar why because we're syncing our
lives together we're making sure that
IPAs are crossing each other and we're
working smarter not harder this the next
thing we use is Monday comm this is what
we use for our productivity and all of
our projects this is where we map things
like YouTube videos and launch schedules
and all of our admin type things that
need to happen in there that's through
Monday comm and the way we communicate
as a team right now is through a
software company called slack now this
is great because it's mobile you can
have the option of adding as many people
as you want and it allows you to keep
communication on certain projects
separated from other projects have you
ever had that before we were talking to
someone and then they just kind of like
switch to a new thing and you're like
wait we were on this topic how are we
over on this topic now right and so what
we use that for is slack and then
pl'anna Lee this is where we plan our
Instagram strategy is on plan 'le as a
company
now we also use so these are the four
main that we use we use the actual
scheduling tools inside of things like
Facebook and Twitter the actual native
scheduling for those platforms but you
guys this is all we're using as a
company right now because we don't have
time for more than this all right the
next of one is saying no more than yes
this is a life changer now when I read
through this book and I heard say no
more than yes that was hard because I'm
the yes girl I'm like you need a leader
maybe you need someone to run this
festival maybe right like I was signing
up for everything I was like the mom of
the PTA that wanted to do it all and
that is not going to move me towards my
goals and so I had to start practicing
saying no more than yes so here's a tool
I want you to take home with you when
someone says hey dr. K can you XY and Z
want you to say you know what that's a
great idea let me think about it because
in the moment if you're like me which is
a three on the India gram you're like
yes sign me up right I am ready for that
I will lead that thing I will do that
thing I will waste a lot of time on your
thing because I want to please you and
so I want you to take some time before
you say yes and really think about it is
this thing going to move me forward in
my business now it's okay if you feel
sometimes like this is good for me and
good for them absolutely then say yes
but you'll start to see as I have in my
life that more times than not it's
actually okay to just say no because
here's the thing other people can do it
too I know it's weird thing I thought
I'm the only one that can do this but
other people are out there they can do
exactly what you can do so I want you to
practice saying no more than yes in
celebration of the launch of this brand
new podcast we're giving away two
tickets to our annual conference grow as
video live a $1,500 value all you have
to do to enter is make sure you
subscribe leave us a review on Apple
podcast and then take a screenshot of
your review and go to think marketing
show.com for the rest of the details and
the last thing really is in my time
management be real with yourself on your
goals versus your expectations this was
something for me that really had to be a
mindset shift because I have lofty goals
I have huge audacious massive goals
where I want to make major impact in the
world but it's the season of life right
it depends on where you are in that
season and for this last year for our
family
we're in a new season of life this
January we were able to bring another
little guy into our home and thank you
and with I'm like still all the mom
feels you know and with that that's a
season of life that needed to be
dedicated more to my family and so when
you're looking through your time
management when you're looking through
productivity a way to think about what
season of life in my in my taking care
of an elderly parent am i adopting am i
needing to actually hustle at Starbucks
to get my thing off the ground like what
season of life are you in and being real
with your expectations through that
because a lot of times the feelings of
failure that we have are actually just
related to our own misconception of our
expectations so number two number two on
that was the lack of resources now I
have been uh I have been as solo
entrepreneur until the time that Shawn
and I created this this until he's
created think media and this for me was
probably one of the largest blockers but
one of my mentors says everything is
figure out able everything is figure out
of all so most of the time these are the
two blockers that come into play when
we're not going all in and pressing
record number one is people let me be
honest and and I want you to be honest
with me it is hard to hire people it's
hard you don't know what you need to
hire them for you're like what do I take
off my plate how long is it gonna take
to train them what should I pay them
should they be a contractor an employee
does my state make me do that or do I
have to do this like all of these new
things that we never learned are now
things on our plate that are gonna help
us move forward so people become the
lack of resource and then knowledge and
skill guys I knew that I was supposed to
be on video and I waited three years I
knew it I knew that the way I needed to
get my message out to the world was on
video and I
didn't do it I was running a digital
agency I was helping a government agency
I was helping other people do their
thing and I was like you go girl you got
that right but then I looked right back
at myself and I was like I don't know
what to do
I don't know anything about cameras I
don't know anything about gear and I've
waited three years before I picked up my
phone and recorded a video and you know
what was really crazy about that too was
when we go back to the people part and
the knowledge and the skills part all it
took was one tweet all it took was one
tweet I stepped out I had courage I
reached out to someone that was already
doing what I want to do and I said let's
partner on this I have these skills I
know I know how to do this thing and I
know you know how to do that thing so
why don't we do this thing together
right you are in this room right now
with other smart purpose-driven
entrepreneurs there is no better place
right now for you to partner with
someone than in this room cuz we're on
mission y'all are we on mission we're on
mission you are Purpose Driven I know
that you have a skill that you can share
with someone so I want to make sure that
you know that people and knowledge and
skills
that's a limiting belief in our brain
there are people that want to connect
with you none of this happened
by just me and Shawn this was people
this is people this is other people's
skill and knowledge the next one the
lack of budget anyone in here ballin on
a budget
yeah well like Sean said before guess
what guys your Excuse is gone all of
these are free and guess what you want
to start a business you're like Heather
I get it social media is free I got that
well guess what all of these things
where you can start a business you can
start emailing people on your list you
can sign up for Amazon Associates and
become a person that sells other
people's products you can package your
knowledge on think epic and teachable
and sir
doing the things that are gonna change
people's life and guess what see that
free all free and guess what it doesn't
take fancy gear it doesn't take a lot of
things guess what it takes that right
there your smartphone all it takes is
your smartphone and if you need help
with that we're here for you for free
crazy we have a new series that just
came out on think media where we walk
you step by step step by step y'all how
to go into video with just your
smartphone and then we also have created
free resources for you if you're like
Heather I'm a step above a smartphone
I'm ready I'm ready to go all-in with
whatever Diane is using on her channel
that looks awesome and what dr. K's over
here doing like you're ready to go in
we've prepared free resources for you as
well all right guys now it's time to get
into those internal enemies those
internal enemies now we've gone through
the first three and those are all
external those are things that were like
yeah I see that and I can do that and I
can hire that person and I can I can do
those things so that I can do the things
but these are really the things that
held me back these are the things that I
allowed to run my life for three years
and the first one is this perfectionism
right I get you I know me too
perfectionism
this is from Beth Moore she says
insecurities best cover is perfectionism
that's where it becomes an art form
that's where perfectionism becomes an
art form
guys here's where perfectionists live
this all-or-nothing syndrome well
Heather I just can't post that video you
know my hair was all messed up and like
I didn't even sound right and like my
kids were yelling in the backgrounds so
I can't post it why are you only gonna
make one video come on right oh you know
I created that course it's sitting on my
laptop but you know it's like there's
not only have an editor and then it's
just I mean who's gonna buy it anyways
are you only going to create one course
I mean didn't we hear Sean say you need
to be making bad videos like let's just
get that out right now you need to be
making bad things first because making
those bad things first starting messy
that is what's gonna move you forward
that is going to be that where someone
pops on Instagram is like who is this
girl they're gonna be like yeah did you
not see they'll like 500 things I messed
up on no they don't see that because you
started messy first so let's go ahead
and just let perfectionism out and let's
start messy next is this one this one
gets me every time
scarcity have you ever said this to
yourself someone's already doing it
someone's already out there someone's
already talking about digital marketing
someone's already out there they're
already a doctor I can't be online
there's there's already doctors online
oh man there's already a painter
there was a painter and she's online
already oh man there's a person that's
already talking about speaking on stage
I can't I just can't do it there's just
not enough people in the world
what am I gonna do not about people that
are gonna buy my stuff or grow my
business or anything like that let me
let's look at these this is digital
around the world in 2019 the total
population we're at 7 billion
oh that's crazy look at that five
billion people have cellphones
what Internet users four billion people
I mean I'm okay if I get 10% of that I
don't know about you guys I will be fine
if it's just 10% of four billion come on
scarcity really Shawn had some numbers
earlier there were active users these
are actually just active accounts like
like LinkedIn your boss said hey you
need to create a LinkedIn account you're
like sure okay whatever LinkedIn account
right these are these are active
accounts on these platforms you're
telling me there's not enough people in
the world guys scarcity is a mindset
there is no lack there is only abundance
and you know what makes it even better
is that you are here at girl with video
life you can partner with someone Sean
and me partnering that didn't make us go
down that made us go up there's no
scarcity you know we are friends with
every major competitor in our market we
are friends with them you know why
because all of that Rises someone else
bringing that to the playing field helps
us in the playing field if there's no
one else doing what you're doing
that's the scary part but I'll bet raise
your hand is someone else doing what
you're doing raise your hand someone
else doing what you're doing exactly
there is more than enough to go around
here's a question for you
how many of you bought a pair of shoes
how many of you have ever bought a pair
of shoes okay one pair of shoes is good
half of you at know shoes that's fine I
mean uh okay um how have you how many of
you have bought two pairs of shoes oh
wow look at that how many of my five
pairs of shoes 10 pairs of shoes I'm
sure every person that started a shoe
company was like there's already people
doing it no here's the thing guys there
is more people in the marketplace right
now that want what you have
they are waiting for you waiting for you
so put your message out in the world
they need it from your voice they need
to connect with you personally they need
to hear your story
that's not scarcity that's abundance
here we go guys man let me know if this
one has gotten you before a lack of
confidence lack of confidence
here's where I fall into it guys I am
standing on a stage in front of 250
people
what is life right now this is crazy but
this is where I fall the imposter
syndrome the impostor syndrome Who am I
Who am I to be the person to be telling
people how to school I just started who
am I to be the person to help someone
through a divorce I'm not but other
people do who am I to be the person
that's gonna help someone learn how to
parent their kids Who am I to be the
doctor that's online helping someone
with their problems Who am I to be the
artist telling someone how they should
be create there's people that are better
than me but you know what doesn't matter
you have permission to step out you have
permission to step out I want you to
turn to your neighbor right now while
you look them in the eye and say you
have permission to do this
now look at the other person and say no
you have permission you should be doing
this there we go
guys imposter syndrome it's just a
mindset I still fight this every single
day there are women who are doing
massive things in the world and I think
Who am I
I'm just said college dropout that lives
in Las Vegas and home spoils my kids but
you know what God has woven a purpose
into my heart and I am going to stand on
every stage that I can and empower as
many people as I can because no one is
gonna tell me that I'm an impostor
because if I believe it they'll believe
it alright here we go
comparison anyone yes oh man this one
hurts yes you know when I think about
this comparison is the thief of joy the
thief of joy I get up every single day
and I want to live a joyful life it
doesn't need to be balanced it doesn't
need to be perfect but the one thing I
want to be known for is I brought joy to
the world and you know what happens when
we start scrolling through Instagram
comparison creeps in you know what
happens when we go to that business
conference that we were like the new
person on the scene comparison starts to
creep in and so I just want to encourage
you that you have something great inside
of you and your journey is gonna look
different than someone else's my path to
get to where I want to go is not going
to be the road that someone else went
down I want to be a trailblazer for the
next generation and I want to do it my
way
but this right here this is what the
enemy is giving me you're not good
enough who are you why are you doing
this there's so much better than you
they're already on a yacht in Cancun
not that that's where I want to go but I
want to go why I mean if it's there I
want to do it but that's the kind of
stuff right Oh their family's perfect
oh wow they're eating organic food wow
she was able to do all these things
comparison is the thief of your joy and
you are the one that controls that you
are the one that picks up your phone and
scrolls through Instagram you're the one
that actually follows those people on
Instagram here's a power tip for you
unfollow power tip unfollow those people
doesn't matter if your sister doesn't
matter if it's the guy that's doing the
other thing does not matter who it is
guys we have been tricked to think that
we need to follow everyone in the world
you don't if they are stealing your joy
if you are not going to these platforms
and feeling fulfilled afterwards then
you need to unfollow I did this I did
this practice actually before we started
girls video live I was feeling down guys
I was feeling like Who am I one of the
idols that I look up to is Rachel Hollis
and she just did a conference with 7,000
women I was like well surely at 250
people coming 250 come on this is
amazing this is awesome and though I
love her so much for the message she's
bringing to the world guess what I did
unfollowed unfollowed and guess what I
wasn't doing leading up to this event
for the last week comparing myself to
her
I was letting people like Mel speak life
into me I was letting people like Shawn
tell me that I was made for this
I was letting people in my life actually
feed me so that I could be here on this
stage y'all this is not normal for me
this is not normal for me but I know
that this is where I need to be so
here's what I want you to know you're
not alone you're not alone in this
thanks for checking out this episode we
hope you got a ton of value and if you
haven't already subscribe here to the
think marketing show wherever you're
watching or
listening and hey it would mean the
world to us if you would rate and review
this show on Apple podcast as we grow
this movement of purpose-driven content
creators we encourage you to share it
with a friend and we'll see you in the
next episode